- Okay, so today what I
want to talk to you about
a little bit is actually
how to drug design.
I feel like this is a very relevant topic,
especially with corona
where, you know,
everybody's talking about,
well, they're talking about vaccines,
but initially they were talking
about what drugs can we use
for people who actually have corona?
You know, how can you alleviate symptoms
when people are coughing,
and need some- you know,
need to reduce inflammation
in your body and their
response to the virus.
So how can we design drugs for that?
And I'll just take a very
simple drug that everybody knows
or most people know.
Advil, right?
You have a headache, you
have, you know, muscle pain.
Most people take Advil.
And that relieves the symptoms.
So Advil is, is the brand name.
Ibuprofen is the actual,
you know, drug name
and that has a certain
chemical structure to it.
And the way they design sort of this,
this molecule to look like this
is that they know exactly how to target.
They know how to
basically design this drug
because they know what the
actual target is of this drug.
So in other words, there's, you know,
some protein or enzyme
that you want to target.
And if you know the structure
of this enzyme or protein
then you can design a drug
that can actually target
that enzyme or protein.
And you may have heard this in AP Bio,
a sort of a model that you
use to describe an enzyme
and some sort of substrate binding to it
is the lock and key model.
And that's, again, you
have some sort of lock
and you're designing a
key that can fit in it.
But again, how do you
design this effective drug?
You have to know exactly
what this lock looks like.
I just want to show you a
little bit of a cool video
and I'll skip around a little
bit just for time purposes.
But there's a company called Schrodinger
that has cool tools
basically to design,
to have basically computational tools
to design certain drugs.
And so I just want to show you this video,
give you a little bit of a
background on what I mean.
(upbeat music playing in video)
Can you hear, by the way? The- okay.
And so here, what they're showing you,
I'll make it a little lower.
They're showing you a protein and a drug
and they're showing you how
the drug goes into this protein
and binds into this protein.
And the proteins are made
up of these amino acids,
they're basically a chain
of all these amino acids,
which again are just carbon molecules
and other molecules as well.
And they can fold into
this particular shape.
And so they have this
three-dimensional structure
which is really important to know
because when you think about proteins
they're not just, you know,
it's not just a flat 2D thing.
A lock is not just a flat 2D thing, right?
It's a three-dimensional structure.
And this protein has
different elements to it.
So now it's just depicting the protein
a little bit of a different way.
I'm going to skip through
this a little bit.
But the most important thing
is that you have this drug
and this drug can make different
contacts with the protein.
It's going to show you now...
Skip around a little bit.
What type of contacts this drug
can make with this protein.
So you can have hydrogen bonds
of this drug to the different,
you know, to the, to the protein.
You can have...
It's going to show you hydrophobic bonds
and, and so forth.
So I'm gonna stop this for right now
because, just for the lack of time,
but the idea is what this is showing you-
one second-
is that you have these,
you have these,
these drugs that make
certain contact points
and chemical, you know,
chemical interactions
with the protein.
And so if you find exactly
what this protein looks like
you can design the drug
to make these contacts.
And so the type of technique that we use
in our lab to actually find
these three-dimensional structures
is called cryo-electron microscopy.
So cryo means cold, right?
So very cold, extreme cold temperatures.
And then you have electro-microscopy
because you actually use this microscope
that shoots electrons into the sample
to visualize that sample.
So I'm just going to
very, very briefly go at-
go through this because I'm
going to show you this soon,
is that usually to get that
three-dimensional structure
of your protein
what you do is you have
your protein solution
and you place it on this small little grid
which is basically the smaller- small-
like smaller than the
tip of your fingertip.
And then you freeze
this and that's, again,
the idea of the cryo condition.
You need to freeze it so that
you get it in one conformation,
in one static structure.
So that way you can image
that static structure
and come up with one conformation
of what that protein looks like
and get a three-dimensional
structure of what that is.
So I'm just gonna go on.
I have to show you.
I think this is sort of
the end of the intro part.
So now we'll go into the lab
and I'll show you exactly
how we do the freezing
of this protein to get that
three-dimensional structure.
So that way you can
eventually design drugs to...
So I'll stop sharing
and I'm going to take you in.
Now I'm just in a conference
room in Rockefeller.
I'll show you a little
bit of the lab as well.
So this is the lab.
There are a few people
who are standing there.
We actually have a little
microscope room over here.
It's a different type of microscope room.
We have some cell (unclear).
- Hi.
- You can see me? Hear me?
- Yeah, we can see you better.
We just launched one of the polls
just as a little quiz
while you got back on.
- Okay. Perfect.
I'm so sorry.
I really hope it doesn't drop.
There's this area we do our experiments,
so it's possible this
area just doesn't have
the best service or wifi.
Okay, so I'm going to do
a little different thing.
So I can show you guys,
I'll show you not exactly the machine
just because there's these
technical difficulties.
But what I'll do is I'll send
you guys a video afterwards
exactly how that machine works.
And instead, I'll show you
the little components of it.
Is that, is that all right?
Improvising a little.
- [Teacher] Yeah.
- Okay.
So what we have here is
I'm going to show you
the grids that we use
and how small they are
and how we put our samples over there.
So the grids look like this.
They're super small.
I'm going to take one out
and you're going to see how tiny they are.
And this is, you can't even,
you can't see the protein
because the protein is like,
I'd say 100 or 200 times
smaller than what this grid is.
It's actually probably
1,000 times smaller.
Oops, it's fallen a little bit, but-
so this is the grid.
I don't know if you can
see how small that is.
- [Teacher] Oh, wow.
- [Ayala] So this is my
finger and this is the grid
so that's how small the grid is.
And you put basically a sample.
You put a,
I'll show you,
a small droplet of let's
say protein on this.
This is not protein
but this will just be a
small whatever solution.
And what you do is you put,
usually you have this grid
and you normally put a
little drop of solution
on top like that.
So you can't even see, but you can see
that there's that grid.
And there's a tiny drop a solution
that you have on top that you've put on.
And you need this grid specifically
because this little thing
sits into a microscope
that's about the size of a room.
So that's how powerful the microscope is
to be able to put electrons
into such a small sample.
That's how much power you need to image
this small tiny sample,
and to see that protein.
So it just gives you a sense of scale
of how much sort of energy you need
to look at something that's so small.
(beeping of lab equipment)
It's like saying an ultra,
you know, microscope
to look at something so small.
Now what I'll do is I'll
show you a little something.
So what you do at this
point is in the machine
what you would do is take liquid nitrogen
and you pour it into the
base of that machine.
And you would basically
plunge freeze your sample.
It's a really cold thing.
You usually plunge freeze
first into liquid ethane,
in this case, and then
store it in liquid nitrogen.
In this case, I'm just taking this grid
and I'm just gonna put
it into liquid nitrogen.
You don't really want to touch this cause
it'll freeze your hand off.
And then what you normally do is
you just plunge very quickly into here.
I'm going to move the phone a little bit.
You can see it becomes
like a little white almost.
I don't know if you can see that.
Can you see that? The grid?
- [Teacher] Yeah.
- [Ayala] And you can see there's
like a little white on top of it.
That's like the sample.
And that's, that's how
the sample's frozen.
And once you have the sample
what you do is you put it
into these tiny little boxes.
I'm going to leave this down for now.
You have these small boxes like this.
And remember, you cannot take that sample
at any point out of liquid nitrogen.
You always have to keep it
there because if you take it out
it's going to dry, it will warm up,
and then your protein
is going to denature.
It's just going to heat up
and the three-dimensional
structure is going to get ruined.
So all this stuff has to be kept
in liquid nitrogen at all times.
So essentially what you
would do in liquid nitrogen.
I'm not showing you all the tools.
You would take this and you'd put it
into the small little box over here to,
to sort of store for
when you image your sample later
in the electron microscope.
- [Teacher] Ayala, why
do you have to freeze
the sample in the first place?
- [Ayala] So you have
to freeze it because-
for a few reasons,
but the main one is you want to sort of
get a static picture of your protein.
You can't just put it in solution.
You need a static picture.
It's too dynamic, basically to be able to
capture a picture and reconstruct
a three-dimensional structure of it.
So imagine if you had a protein
that's constantly moving.
It's almost like saying
a blurry picture, right?
If somebody is running
it's really hard to
capture what they look like
because you have a blurry picture, right.
But if you have somebody
just standing in place
then what happens is you
can capture that, you know
they're- what they look like
if they're just standing in place.
So, and in addition to that
there's some other technicalities
of having a certain ice thickness
so that the electrons can
go through it as well.
So you need to a certain type of ice
for the electrons to
sort of permeate through.
- [Teacher] Thank you.
- [Ayala] Yeah. So I'm trying to think
if we should do- if I should
show you some other things.
How much time do we have right now?
I'm just curious, just that I can,
should- should I go on to questions
or should I show more than the...
- [Teacher] I think we
could do with questions
unless you have something else that may be
like a couple more minutes
and then we should go with questions.
Go to questions.
- [Ayala] Okay. Yeah.
So I guess, I guess we'll,
we'll stick with questions
just because I didn't
have it planned exactly.
- [Teacher] Okay, fine. Great.
(unclear) Great. Perfect.
- [Odaelys] Ayala, I
launched one of the polls,
the first one, and they got
a hundred percent correct
while you were gone.
- [Ayala] Okay. So
everyone's already retaining
exactly what we're doing.
- [Teacher] We only have about like
five minutes left anyway.
So, so let's open up for questions.
So girls, do you have any questions
on the techniques or in general
or what Ayala was doing or [Indistinct]?
- [Student] So if you aren't originally,
like you're taking the
sample in the solution
and then you're free-
you're like freezing it.
Why would it denature when you're-
when taken out of the liquid nitrogen
if it wasn't denaturing, like, before?
- [Ayala] Yeah. Well. yeah. (unclear)
So there's always a risk basically
of freeze-thawing your protein
because what happens is
you basically, you have it in this,
this- basically first you
have it in a solution, right?
And then you freeze it.
But if you freeze it, it's possible
there's ice crystals that form,
it's possible that when you, you know,
it's at a certain
temperature, there may be,
there's aggregates of the protein.
And so when you unfreeze
it, there's always a risk
of basically having some
protein that goes bad.
And so actually, anytime you,
you let's say freeze a protein
in -80 degrees or something
you always have to spin it down again.
So that way the good protein
stays in your solution
but the bad protein
that basically denatured
goes to the bottom, in pellets.
And so just on a technical level
you have that little grid, right?
You basically have three
microliters of a droplet on there.
If you take it out and thaw it out,
you would hypothetically,
you need to just take
those three microliters
and then spin it down again,
so you wouldn't have all this protein,
half the protein denatured
in your solution.
So it's technically,
you can't technically do that
once it's already on the grid.
But yeah, the short answer is that
you always have that risk
whenever you freeze-thaw
because of ice crystal formation.
And because of either aggregates
in the solution that when frozen
they basically just fall apart.
I don't know, that- does
that make sense a little bit?
- [Student] Yeah.
- [Ayala] Okay.
- [Teacher] So why will- I guess also
Why won't they freeze?
Why are they good if you're freezing them?
Why don't they denature
when you freeze them?
- [Ayala] Yeah. So sometimes
you do have that issue,
but a lot of times what you will do
is incorporate certain things inside.
Like, you know, when
let's say you freeze cells
you incorporate like glycerols
or something like sugars
or you put, sometimes you
put in these detergents
if there is that risk.
So every sample is a little bit different
but when you freeze it, when
the actual freezing happens
it's so quick in the liquid
ethane that it doesn't denature
but there are some proteins that don't,
that don't retain their
structure like that.
And so that, that's, you know, sometimes
and you have to optimize your conditions,
like again putting in detergents or sugars
that will help stabilize
it during that process.
- [Teacher] Any other questions, girls?
- [Student] I have a question.
- [Ayala] Okay. Go ahead.
- [Student] I don't know if this is like,
I just missed this,
but the, like, how was-
how does the protein, when you put it on,
like how does it just stay there?
Cause like, you were holding the grid
at different angles and
it just was staying on it.
- [Ayala] Yeah. Well, so I
didn't get to show you this
but normally what we do
actually in the machine,
it's a really cool machine.
I'll- I'll send you guys
a video to check out
but what you normally do
is actually blot your grid.
So you basically take, and
maybe I should show this before,
but you basically take like a paper
like a filter paper and you blot it.
So you have the grid here and
then you have the filter paper
and it slams down like that.
And it absorbs the liquid.
And as it absorbs, what
happens is the protein sticks
to the, on the other side, right?
So you have the droplet here,
you have the grid over here
and then you have the filter paper.
And as the liquid goes through the grid
into the filter paper, it's absorbed.
And then you have the
protein that sort of sticks
to the side of the grid and
just kind of stays there.
And then immediately after it gets frozen.
So you have that
because you have that
step, it helps it stick.
And in addition to that, the car- the grid
that little small thing
actually has a piece
of carbon
and basically
carbon sticks to a lot of things.
It sticks to, it will always
have things stick to it.
So it helps sort of
bring the protein there.
But so there's an extra step, essentially.
I'm just saying, I, I didn't know anything
about this before I
came to graduate school
but you learn a lot when you have do it.
And it's a really cool technique
that really, like, if you think about it
if you look at a cell
underneath a microscope
even just like a Brightfield microscope,
that's, you know,
you're just looking at
it in that microscope.
But what you're looking
at here is a protein
which is how many times smaller?
Like 1,000 or you know,
100,000 times smaller.
So that's the scale
that you're looking at.
It's just insane that you have technology
that you can see such a small thing.
It's like saying, looking
at a planet, another planet,
you know, from our, from Earth.
Like, it's just unbelievable.
So yeah.
That's my little rant about that, but...
Is there, are there any other questions
about just the technique
itself or even just...
- [Student] I have a question.
- [Ayala] Mm-hmm?
- [Student] What does
the protein look like
under the microscope?
- [Ayala] Yeah. So basically you end up
getting these images.
I'm - I wonder if I can
show you, I showed in the,
in the screenshot, but basically
you see these (unclear)
I'm so sorry.
I really have never had so
many technical difficulties
in my life.
So I'm going to actually share screen,
just if you can enable
share screen and I'll,
I'll answer that question.
Okay. So I'm going to share screen.
So this is the original slide that I had
and what the image that
you see is literally this.
It's like a gray scale and you
see those little black dots?
That's the image that you get out of it.
I know that's crazy because
you can't see anything
but in reality, if you
pick out like a lot,
a lot of these proteins inside,
and sort of this goes
into the processing
part, but what you do is
you pick out all these different
images of these proteins
and you end up averaging
these images together.
And what you can do is basically,
all you have to know is
you get this image and,
and by doing post-processing
and computational things
you can get out all the
details of that image.
So you literally get something like this,
where it's like a gray...
I'll show you another pretty picture
of what it looks like.
(sound of typing)
(beeping of lab equipment)
Let me show you.
One second.
Here we go.
So
I'm going to show you a different picture.
So this is an actin filament.
I don't know if you've
learned about actin and myosin
in AP bio.
So you have these actin filaments.
And when you image on this
is what they look like,
these filaments, like this, and eventually
after post-processing, what
you can get is a structure
like this, where you can
see a lot of details.
And in these details, you ended up getting
a three-dimensional
structure where you can build
from amino acids, these
three-dimensional conformations
of these proteins.
And so it's crazy how
you get, when you use
an electron microscope, you
get a picture like this,
it looks like a gray.
You have all these gray values
and you have your proteins that, you know,
look like sort of again
like gray sort of blobs.
And eventually you can computationally
get a three-dimensional structure
of what that looks like.
I don't know if there
are any other questions
regarding again,
the technique how, or...
- [Teacher] Yeah, I think they have to go
to the next class.
- [Ayala] Okay.
- [Teacher] So-
- [Ayala] All right.
Well, if anybody has any questions
even just regarding
future planning of your career
or anything at any
point you can reach out.
And I apologize again
for not having exactly shown,
show what I intended to show
but hopefully it was still interesting.
(chuckles)
- [Odaelys] Yeah.
- I'll definitely get the videos to you
Thank you so much for doing this.
Sorry, guys.
The wifi just is not great.
(laughing)
(unclear)
- [Teacher] This is amazing.
Thank you for taking your time.
We know you're so busy
so thanks for taking the
time and recording this.
And it was really great, so yeah.
Okay. And we'll be in touch.
- [Ayala] Okay.
- [Teacher] Okay.
- [Ayala] Have a great day.
- [Teacher] Thank you. Bye.
- [Ayala] Bye, guys.
- [Student] Thank you.